the human mind is negatively biased and
the reason it's negatively biased
because it's protective mechanism you
know when you look at
um human neurodevelopment in fact human
development at all we haven't really
changed much
in thousands of years we we really
haven't changed think of how different
the world was in 300 years ago let alone
thousands of years our brain and the
reason it's negatively biased is because
it's a protective mechanism like if if
for example
um we walk out into that we walk into
the forest and it's full of wolves and
those wolves could kill us we get away
from that situation and survive the next
time we walk into the forest we're going
to be very weary and think negatively
there's probably wolves in there because
it protects us you know that's
that is an important protective
mechanism as is anxiety you know
adrenaline and all these things you know
it's a fight or flight to deal with a
problem that's in front of us and you
know we retain memories because memories
allow us to learn from the past and make
decisions in the present that make our
future more certain you know our
self-preservation is like the number one
goal for humans as individuals on the
race we need to survive and so we
survive by learning sticking together
broadly acting in the present but
worrying about the future the problem is
that modern day Society not for everyone
I'm talking broadly for a lot of people
we perhaps don't have that kind of fight
or survive or life or death in every
moment of Our Lives most moments that
we're sat here now quite safely you know
we're not under immediate threat sat
here but our minds as we said have not
changed in thousands of years and so
they will fixate on things the
negatively biased mindset will always
fixate on worries and it will spend time
ruminating on the past where people talk
about depression is because of a
rumination in the past and anxiety being
our Obsession of the outcomes of the
future but we're living these
experiences in the present moment and
the problem is with imposter syndrome
and why everyone experiences it because
that negatively biased mind is trying to
protect us from outcomes negative
outcomes the problem is is that
sometimes it is overbearing into our
detriment so
um we might think oh I I can't give this
uh talk on
um alcohol's effect on the on the liver
in front of all these people I'm an
imposter actually that person you might
be a registrar in liver studies you
spent the last six months reading the
papers you've just published an article
around you know you are an expert is
what my point is but yet we feel still
feel the inner child often in times
vulnerability when negativity takes over
we actually go back to our inner child
and we forget everything that we've
experienced we go back to that
vulnerable state of like oh my gosh like
what am I doing here I mean I remember
my first day in Kings on the wards and I
went to prescribe paracetamol I had a
sudden moment of panic of genuinely like
what am I doing here get me out here I
can't remember the dose of paracetamol I
literally turned to the nurse I was like
oh my God I'm feeling really bad like in
like I feel just like and she knew
almost she was like it's fine it's just
the first few days you're just feeling
you know you feel imposter a little bit
like that's it happens and it's the
negative mindset now I I think
people wonder oh wow would be great to
get rid of imposter syndrome I don't
think it would entirely because you
become an egomaniac I think you're
amazing everything it's great to have a
perspective of like I'm good but not
perfect yeah or I'm valid or worthy of
this but maybe I'm not perfect I can
still learn that's really important but
if you let a imposter syndrome can take
over your life it can prevent you doing
anything and I almost think it's worth
remembering I have a saying and I always
say to myself what is the worst that can
happen and I know that sounds if I'm
going to bring you know lightning to be
struck on me it's not what I mean and
it's not even a throwaway of like oh
what's the what's gonna happen I don't
care that's not what I mean
I literally mean what is the worst case
here so if I'm getting up to do a talk
um about mental health you know you
talked about when you
um you know you've done many Keynotes
but say doing Keynotes uh on YouTube or
productivity or business in front of a
lot of people you might think oh gosh
I'm doing this they might be like quite
good entrepreneurs in the room I'm
speaking about this what's the worst
that can happen genuinely you make an
absolute fool yourself that's the worst
that can happen and like really the
worst case you make an absolute fool
yourself partly you probably haven't but
you might feel that you have you're
still alive you're still recoverable you
can still be a successful business
person you can still have a valid
enjoyable life you have to laugh with
your friends you can eat dinner
afterwards we often think that the
outcomes are so much worse than they are
in most scenarios
they're not truly the case and so I
think it's sometimes applying a bit of
perspective to imposter syndrome gets
you
get to you past that mindset you know I
had it I mean I sat down with Boris
Johnson when he was prime minister I was
in Margaret Thatcher's room in number
10.
right and the picture of Margaret
Thatcher was above his head and he was
sat there and I was presenting to him
everything that I'd found out from all
the experts I'd spoke to from the
Charities from the Royal colleges to
kind of tried kind of garnered all this
kind of stuff that we'd put together and
I was taking it to him imagine how much
of an imposter I felt but I literally
said to myself because I felt I felt it
coming on before I went in the room and
I thought I was feeling almost panic and
I thought what's the worst gonna happen
yeah I'm in this room for half an hour
max it'll be done worst case scenario I
never become anywhere near this place
ever again I just run away it's fine I'm
Survivor which is the same as what uh
most people's position is already that
yeah they're not going to be a really
good so the worst case scenario is like
you go back to you know you just got it
I think sometimes imposter syndrome it's
asking yourself what's the worst that
can happen it's realizing that everyone
can feels I have never met anyone in my
life I'm sure there are a few people out
there but I'd argue that probably
they're not in the spectrum of normal
that that most people will feel at
certain times that they are an imposter
most people feel that and therefore feel
a degree of comfort and also realize you
would you know I remember I remember
once um doing um as an SHO do nobs and
Guy now I was doing a night shift with a
consultant new consultant she's like I
feel like a complete imposter I was like
what you've done all this training
you're literally I just watched her do a
surgery she was literally so skilled I
mean she was so slick she was just like
she bossed it I was like
feel like an imposter she's like yeah
absolutely
and I had this real realization I was
like wow everyone I've just seen this
person it's probably one of the skilled
people
but in life and they're smashing this
and they feel like an imposter you
realize everyone feels like it it's not
that bad a thing when those feelings
come on board look for evidence look for
evidence for the fact your imposter then
write down all the evidence of the fact
you're not and I will nine times out of
ten you'll find out that you're not an
imposter and you know what if perhaps it
does highlight somewhere that is an
issue then deal with it say you're doing
a new rotation in medicine and a new
rotation is in something really well say
you're doing like um HIV as a rotation
okay first of all you're not going to be
like taking over and having to know
everything about HIV so often remember
imposter syndrome a lot of the time it's
because you think suddenly like
everything's on you or like the world
will collapse it's not gonna collapse if
you don't know anything about HIV you'll
go in there the consultant will assess
your kind of knowledge capabilities
they'll always have be there to guide
you and so on but it might highlight the
fact that you haven't looked up HIV for
a long time you need a bit of work and
revision so always look at things and
think what is this highlighting why do I
feel this way what's the average
foreign to the contrary and actually if
there is a learning outcome like maybe
before I start HIV uh rotation in a few
weeks time I'll spend four or five hours
reading up on HIV and learning and all
of a sudden you feel bolstered and you
feel better
hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day bye